there's a pretty obvious difference
between the pros and regular players
we miss our shots but the pros
they're not supposed to whiff however
everyone noob or pro whiffs it from time
to time that's just how it is unlike us
though when the best players in the
world with with tournaments reputation
and cash on the line it can be
absolutely brutal to watch before we get
into all of that though i'm gonna need
to make sure you aim at the subscribe
button and don't whiff when you hit the
notification bell
all right you done good because now it's
time to rank the top 10 whiffs in
esports
history starting off our list is shazam
showing that even aim gods can whiff
great running back they're closing
distance on this offer big time jazz
pushing all the way in he misses the
daggers i think it's shorty my goodness
a hundred these that's such a break but
signals are at least striking back
during the vct na challengers 2
qualifiers sentinels were up against 100
thieves were pushing into a site on
ascent
but dicey was waiting for them
underneath heaven with an op sick took
the first shot giving suzanne time to
pop the jet alt smoke out the op dash in
and completely whiff every single dagger
great run it back they're closing
distance on this offer big todd jazz
pushing all the way in he misses the
daggers i think it's shorting my
goodness a hundred thieves that's such a
break but signals aren't striking back
of course dicey pulled out the shorty
and blasted him in the face sentinels
did end up winning the series but
shazam's whiff should be a reminder that
jet knives are more like scalpels than
shotguns it's about precision
our number nine slot goes to the time
kerrigan had 12 shots and whiffed every
single one
oh my lord that should not happen at iem
gamescom 2015 kenny s was stuck in a 1v2
with seconds to plant the bomb kerrigan
knew that so he slipped out from behind
a wall and ran to him with a pistol
unfortunately that didn't exactly work
out for him this is gonna be very
difficult he doesn't have like any time
to work with the bomb plans can take
five seconds alone he's gonna go for it
behind the fountain carrick just gonna
charge him down he's gonna miss quite a
few pistol shots kenny yeah what a kill
kerrigan should not have but then
that's right kerrigan shot his entire 12
bullet mag and still didn't kill kenny
who survived with one hp and clutched
out the round
warping into our number eight slot our
phonics whiffed black holes a complete
whiff once again month funny posh i mean
well getting saved by the shout gray psn
was hoping to be able to target him but
now he's completely out of mana enigma's
black hole is one of the best team fight
ultimates in dota but even the pros have
trouble actually landing it sometimes
for example when navi faced vega and the
esl won new york 2015 qualifiers funic
whiffed not one not two but three black
holes in the same game they've actually
managed to lock down psm while the black
hole gets laid out but again it only it
doesn't catch anything at all it's any
pops the ultimate but the rest of it
squadron has actually retreated now no
one goes back in just going in and out
long jump most will be pulled back oh
the [ __ ] ole miss is funny he tried to
grab no one and now this pl is going to
run rampant a complete whiff once again
on funic posh i mean well getting saved
by the shout gray psn was hoping to be
able to target him but he now he's
completely out of mana enigma's black
hole is a four second channel that
disables and sucks in all teammates in
its aoe with his teammates on aoe damage
heroes like gyrocopter and shadow fiend
a well-timed black hole would easily
wombo combo vega out of the game but
with whiffs like that navi were the ones
who got knocked out of the qualifiers
exploding into our number seven slot is
the time tens blew himself up with a
rosa alt lying down but i mean tens is
gonna force the issue goes through
actually kills himself the last person
you'd expect whiff with a gigantic aoe
rocket launcher is tense but that is
exactly what happened during the vct
masters grand finals in reykjavik
now the question is what is the response
from fnatic you can't really take a loss
that early on lying down but i mean tens
is gonna force the issue goes through
actually kills himself tens is whit
sorry trade secured enough space for
sentinels to plant win the round and
eventually take the series but more
importantly
led to some amazing roasting at least
i've never killed myself to my own
result so
he did in a pro match he did it in a pro
he did it in a pro match i don't care if
he did it we have to put that in that
was so funny
returning to our list in the number six
slot is kerrigan this time completely
within insanely easy shot on dust 2. he
could get this gun there is a player cat
though oh no he hasn't done it he's been
killed no not like this you really hate
to see it you just hate to see it man
during dreamhack open tours 2019
kerrigan was in a 1v5 with the bomb on
the other side of the map fortunately he
had the jump on otto who was looking
a-long letting kerrigan sneak up on him
from a site for an easy pick
unfortunately
this happened instead he could get this
gun there is a player cat though oh no
he hasn't done it he's been killed no
not like this you really hate to see it
you just hate to see it man
at our halfway mark we have naenae's
whiffed graviton so nene as he's moving
over he just sees a flash a hint out of
the corner of his eye his peripheral
vision
then he's got the eyes of a hunter and
he sees michelle over there and so just
decides to absolutely heat his grave but
michelle has no idea that he's dodged
this during the owl 2019 stage one
playoffs nyxl were one grab combo away
from claiming victory over seoul dynasty
but michelle sombra was on the flank
threatening a massive emp to counter the
play nene on zarya caught a tiny glimpse
of sombra and saw red he threw it all
away to try to solo grab her and to end
the round right there but he completely
whiffed could be a game-winning series
winning emp right here it really could
but look at all the ultimates here for
the nyxl six online dynasty a bit
further behind to grab not there for
fled up they can still make this work
but it's gonna be in overtime as they
work their way
it doesn't do jack makko throws a bomb
into the back of this place trying to
find something by the emp comes in
the shatter's absolutely huge shoulder
trying to keep him alive and a novel
gets picked out
without the grav the rest of nyxl
couldn't push into the point and were
altered out of the game by seoul
knocking them out of the playoffs
in our number four slot we have c9s
shinobi double whiffing against envy
either way
looking like
about to get a challenge in towards me
but he actually makes it through at the
phase invitational shinobi was watching
b heaven on split when envy pushed in on
him somehow defying all the odds shinobi
perfectly traced caboose and akus's
outlines with his spray for a glorious
double whiff but to make it even better
just as that was happening mame and tens
were in a 1v1 duel on b
both of them whipped out their alts and
oh
no one else can do it so he's had to do
it for them that's right in the span of
just 10 seconds shinobi whiffed on two
mummy whipped his knives and tens rosa
ulted himself
have you ever seen something more
beautiful
for our bronze metal spot we have an
oldie but a goodie simple classic
whiffed knife if it does happen now
that's gonna be one of the silliest
knife attempts ever like don't if you're
able to close out a game don't knife
anyone please it's for money essentially
do not do with the showboat it doesn't
matter during the upper bracket
semifinal at esl one cologne simple
tried to knife nitro from behind to
claim map point when everything went
wrong hey matt point looking
to be confirmed
[Music]
got knifed simple of course trying to
push it through
and it's in style
pulling it off which is surprising
himself off stuff like that to be fair
but he just calls him a thrill i agree
completely i agree completely
in our runner-up spot is blabber showing
how one whiff can lead to absolute
disaster
that is the worst scuttle take i have
ever seen in my life all right well
cloud9 you've dug yourself a hole and
that whole name is blabber uh not a good
start however as people come back into
lanes top lane equals ces bot lane
equals cs during msi 2021 c9's blabber
spotted steel in the river taking
scuttle what happened next is either the
best or worst scuttle take in league of
legends history
but being zoned out he's gonna try get
stunned take a bunch of damage flashes
to smite a scuttle crab the bladder be
careful where is your team he's at 200
hp that is the worst scuttle take i have
ever seen in my life
so because blabber whipped his spear he
decided to over commit burned flash to
take scuttle and then died for it what
was he thinking
taking the number one spot on this list
is nico's million dollar whiff
and simple sitting
an absolute disaster
during the grand finals of the stockholm
major g2 were just one round away from
forcing game three against navi and nico
was in a perfect position to secure kill
on simple to do it all he had to do was
hit one headshot with his deagle that is
simple
to perfection
and simple sitting no no
an absolute disaster unfortunately for
nico the shots went wide and whether he
pulled the trigger too late or moved his
cursor at the last millisecond it led to
his death that is an absolute
heartbreaker
alright folks that's our list if you
think we missed anything that was
heartbreaking or hilarious let us know
down in the comment section below take
care and i'll see you in the next one
raise a main is he gonna clear me with
that
no he didn't he did not clear me he did
not clear me holy
it's christmas
you're dead